Anthony just hurry up and get to the
[ __ ] thank you thank you Ryan
I should fire him you have some Pro
talibators news don't you Taliban
apologist
[Music]
and in tell the bad news oh
depending on who you talk to that's more
Taliban stuff yeah I always try to fight
stuff for you guys thank you I love
fighting I hate fight stuff I love it
why do you hate it don't isn't that your
passion
not really but this is among the most
pop culture of fight news can I guess
absolutely you can get it Jake Paul no
it's not that would be a very oh
interesting fighting honest with Silva
which is crazy it's crazy that is crazy
amateur street fights on that pop-up on
my reels We're Not Gonna derail this
topic just yet you guys watch Street
beefs what I like what I like we're
derailing what I like what I like this
one on the things that pop up on the
Explorer when it's amateur street fight
but one of them is trained oh they beat
the [ __ ] out of the other person that's
not that's not even fair that's my
favorite you know what I like is there's
we are officially there's a girl in a
bikini and she's turning around and
she's trying to sit on your face on the
but then you're just and then you want
to click that but then there's a fight
going on and there's a you want to click
that and you're just like which one is
the video to see right now I click both
of them and to see which one pops up
double cursor or anything what's the
fight news Anthony just hurry up and get
to the [ __ ] thank you thank you Ryan
I should fire him you have some Pro
talibators news don't you Taliban
apologist
news one day they're gonna realize that
this show would not have been possible
without are you guys gonna design yeah
it's true because we don't cover Taliban
news
we're gonna design the new king just
suicide guys Mayweather news oh oh he's
gonna fight he said he wants to fight
Conor McGregor in 2023. oh again I saw a
rumor that he's gonna fight ksi's
brother what isn't he gonna do an
exhibition fight with that Japanese dude
he is doing that exhibition fight that's
happening really Floyd Mayweather gonna
fight everybody he can to make some
cheddar yeah because he's retired right
in the Conor fight though he says he
would do it as a real fight not
exhibition what do you mean like a real
fight like for his record was the first
one in an exhibition his the first one
was exhibition wasn't it no no that was
a real that's a real one oh that was in
his favor still yeah yeah that was 50-0
but he he would put it on the line again
his 50-0 time because Logan Logan Paul
was exhibition so for example at the
Logan Paul one they can't knock each
other out so it just it's just a show
you know it's like the holy field in May
uh the [ __ ]
um Tyson Roy Jones Jr and the time that
was an exhibition fight yeah so stuff
like that are it's like man I want to
see a real one if you guys don't really
do but you can't knock each other out is
that the difference if it's an
exhibition fight in the contract they're
like we're not gonna knock each other
out we're not gonna do this We're not
gonna do this but it could be an
accident no but it's a it looks like a
spa it looks like sparring it's like
your body shots only agreement yeah yeah
I like that because they don't want to
lock the for example with uh Conor
McGregor's and Mayweather's first fight
in the contract it says I think like if
Conor throws a kick even accidentally
it's like a hundred thousand dollar fine
that's too much money like that too much
money expensive kick but at the same
time Conor walked away from that fight
with a hundred million dollars and uh
Floyd walked away with 300 million
dollars that's why Conor that's why
Connor has a boat you see that boat that
he has totally what
on this next one too Floyd has said that
uh again their their first fight was in
2017 as one of the most watched and
talked about combat sporting events ever
Floyd is rumored to have made 300
million dollars in Conor 100 million for
the first bout wow Mayweather has made
it clear that obviously a ridiculously
big check would come his way for a
second fight he said you know we got to
start at least 100 million for Floyd
Mayweather uh it's also significant that
Floyd's had a real fight meaning not an
exhibition in a pro bout which Floyd
says he wants his perfect 50-0 record
would be on the line
May while Mayweather also revealed the
likely location which is the Raiders new
football stadium the Allegiant stadium
is so sick dude that'd be crazy I think
it fits roughly 65 000 fans trip the
amount of people held by many boxing
venues who wants it there may weather
wants it Mayweather Mayweather's it has
said all of this in some sort of like
kind of uh elusive passing of
information he's kind of like he's down
for it he said that the the promoters or
whatever you know have approached him
and he said it has to be at the
Allegiant Stadium because he said that
he talked to Connor about it and like
that's what they might have wanted or
would want that'd be insane I don't
think I've seen like a boxing match at a
football stadium I mean nuts but in a
recent response to Floyd Mayweather's
interview with TMZ about this stuff
Connor responded with a tweet that was
just a piece and hashtag not interested
so I saw that and I don't like Connor's
such a PR genius that might be before PR
yeah I don't know if it's a truly not
interested or if he's trying to like
feel frustrate the audience and go why
not and then yeah build high places I
would assume that he's also on tons of
cocaine right now dude oh really bro
have you seen his videos no losing his
mind really he's hell of buff right now
what if that too is prg and I'm the one
that [ __ ] you know your phone is this
does he still play on his yacht I I like
the yacht ones where he's like I'm still
losing fights but I got a yacht there's
one where he was eating like a
strawberry ice cream and he's just
laughing the whole time and it's like
he's laughing hysterically and it's
really fun and you're like dude this guy
is
he's lost his mind it seems like you
think you think there's real hate like
within all the like every person that he
fights or do you think is all for PR I
think for him yeah it's all PR who
McGregor yeah there's no hate he knows
because even with the Habib fight oh
yeah Habib had the hate Habib was like
he he said the reason why he fought his
cornerman was because he was like I
thought we were fighting for war like I
thought we really had real beef and then
in between the rounds there's footage of
Conor and if you guys don't know leading
up to that fight there was a bunch of
like trash talk they were like talking
[ __ ] to each other McGregor threw a
chair at the bus stop like it was crazy
like a lot of theatrics theatrics on
McGregor's part and in between rounds
when when Habib is beating his ass like
against the fence yeah Connor looks at
him and goes he's like it's only
business
mate that's what he says to him and then
Habib like he kind of flipped the switch
and was like yo what the [ __ ] and he
said right after he heard him say that
and after he won the fight
he just felt like dude he was just angry
and empty because he said I thought we
were gonna [ __ ] fight and this dude
was just
doing this for show and he's playing him
a little bit yeah and he felt like he
got played so he was like I'm gonna
smash someone's face so you try to beat
up his car and that's why the fight
broke out that's what he was saying it
was like his side of the story khabib
said he was he is admitting to it yeah
he was like dude I I thought we were I
was training so hard to kill this guy
like I thought we were going to go to
war I thought he was gonna bring the
same energy like that's [ __ ] up the
leaked in cage audio uh in cage audio
you hear could be going like let's talk
now brother talk now but he's just
punching on beating the [ __ ] out of him
and you hear Connor going it was just
business it's just business and it could
be like talk now brother and he's just
like beating the [ __ ] out of him because
I think like in khabib he took it to his
took it personally he's defending his
family you don't [ __ ] talk [ __ ] about
Muslims meme I found or nothing and
Connor's I'm just trying to sell a fight
yeah yeah
great would you guys take it like that
if somebody was to say crazy [ __ ] about
you well I also know that to be smart
enough that that guy could be takes his
fight very seriously and he doesn't do
it like for he's not a like a money
driven fighter if I grew up with
Pakistan I would take that [ __ ] for real
you know there's also already gone so
far with who he
who it's not like he can just change it
because he gets it exactly that's why
Conor and Mayweather work perfectly for
each other because they both understand
that well they're both showmen yeah
deflate the purse like together oh yeah
with the [ __ ] they do you know yeah like
one of the one of the uh they did like
this three City media tour and then
Connor had this like sick ass pinstripe
suit and what was dope is when you zoom
in instead of lines it says [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you it just says
[ __ ] you fine print all over this
[ __ ] so he just knows to that detail
of like how to like get people riled up
you know and get people talking about
them no I like this I would know that
the game that's the game like I think
it's a part of the mental game
like you don't want to be affected by
any of that but you also want to be
a good show person unless my mentality
was like I'm a fighter fighter okay
that's what could be with yeah so if
your mind is that it's going to be
difficult for you to understand that
level of entertainment yeah but to you
guys do you guys still enjoy the fights
the same because you know it's for
business I like it all dude I like it
all too I like it all I love all the
because it's so it is interesting about
the fight game you get so many different
characters from all over the world yeah
especially like MMA you you get guys
from Kazakhstan you guys from [ __ ]
like uh all the Asian Fighters out of
one FC you get all these dudes and such
an international sport that everybody
watches it everyone is starting to grow
towards it so you're going to see a lot
of these interesting characters from
different cultures and different
backgrounds and that's going to be fun
too like the Hamza guy yeah they call
them come shot why do they call them is
[ __ ] his name is his name is hamzat
chimayev and he's like this crazy
chechnya dude he has like a cleft lip
and everything looks crazy oh yeah and
he just yells at people's like I want to
kill everybody
[ __ ] and then on on the other
side there's this guy named Colby
Covington who is like uh oh the cowboy
or like Trump sport that's your shtick
right very pro wrestling and he calls
him [ __ ] shot
he goes him come shot and it's like
really funny but it's like where would
you ever see this guy who's being a full
heel professional wrestler type Magna
guy yeah talking to [ __ ] to this guy
from chechnya and calling him making fun
of his name saying like I don't know why
he's mad at me he should be mad at his
mom for calling him [ __ ] shot that's his
a name right like you would never you
would never get these these interactions
from guys from across the world like
that and they're eventually probably
gonna fight like that's gonna be fun I
love that you get you get the narratives
of like pro wrestling that you grew up
watching and then they actually beat
each other's ass for real yeah like it's
[ __ ] incredible you'll never see that
everywhere and then the crazy part is
like the the context and the backstory
where like uh Jorge mazvidal who's like
from the streets of like Miami he caught
Colby Covington was being a showman at
like a restaurant and he socked them up
on the streets you know so it's like
some people keep they understand it's a
show I'm putting it on and some people
take it seriously like the Diaz brothers
too so it's just the craziest Clash so
fights happen in the ring outside of the
Ring [ __ ] DMS and all of it all of
it's the show for us stood over that
[ __ ] yeah it's crazy speaking of Diaz he
just fought a couple weeks ago this is
real quick but the rock started
sponsoring the UFC fighters with his own
brand of shoes yeah and Nate Diaz when
he
everybody was he was getting mad at the
Rock for supporting Jorge so this past
couple weekends ago this dude picks up
his shoe and he's like he's wearing the
rock shoe he's like these shoes [ __ ]
suck he's like [ __ ] The Rock I gotta
wear these dumbass shoes [ __ ] like
live on air and they're like oh [ __ ] we
gotta cut the feet
like [ __ ] hilarious you'll never get
it is his last fight on the UFC contract
he's like they have to wear those shoes
yeah that's what I like a lot of loose
cannons exactly and like that's what
makes it so fun you really you don't get
that in the NBA well you might get a
couple guys but they're just straight up
some are businessmen and some are just
straight up Brawlers wild boys but then
franchises clash in real time yeah it's
really cool awesome but it's crazy that
you gotta accept that if you're just
eating dinner with your family somebody
that you was gonna fight and can come
and just sock you in the face you just
got an exception as a fighter yeah cause
you got to know who you're talking [ __ ]
are you talking to a showman are you
talking someone that lives by this card
right now and it's also to your benefit
because the purse grows you know with
every [ __ ] interaction it really does
yeah it's kind of weird it builds the
story and to confirm yes uh Mayweather
is fighting a boxing Japanese MMA star
mikuru asakura this weekend and then in
November he's also gonna fight ksa's
brother deji is that an exhibition
against the Japanese I believe that's a
they're both exhibited they did the
promo in Hawaii I don't like these
exhibitions so I don't know
I mean like where they're gonna do it
because the last one they did that
Japanese kickboxer boy they did it in
Japan oh yeah attention yeah he made
that fool look amateur as hell
[Music]
[Music]
okay